okay the meeting is now live on YouTube
thank you and welcome everybody sorry
for our delayed a delayed start this
afternoon this is a licensing
subcommittee hearing for the application
for the grant of a new premises license
at 67 Aires Road you know in Old
Trafford what I'm going to do is
introduce everybody that's in the
meeting so everybody knows who else's
who else is here
and then just treat ring and just read
through the protocols for how this it
will and this meeting will will continue
so people present that's myself
counselor and the field as chair of this
meeting my colleagues councillor Jarmon
and councillor but make up three members
of the licensing sort of committee also
got in the room Ruth Worsley and Alex
Murray from democratic services John
Boyle and Kieran Hinchcliffe from the
licensing team along with Emma Sharples
from legal services on behalf of the
applicant
there's mr. Gregson the agent dang and
mr. Zhu the applicant and then on behalf
of the representers mr. who so far is
here but mr. Mohammed Salim will speak
on behalf of mr. who's the pharmacist
afternoon I think that's everybody
that's taking part in them in the
meeting there may be other people
present who are here simply to observe
this afternoon so this meeting is being
live-streamed on YouTube and should that
live stream to stop at any point it
can't be restarted participants been
advised of any backup link we may
adjourn for a short time if we've have
any issues with IT so please just bear
with us if that is the case we do have
all the written state
in front of us and we'll award gee wait
today's as we feel appropriate should we
lose anybody from this meeting please
mute your microphones to minimize
background noise they're all currently
muted at this time and the meeting will
follow the order of hearing everybody
who will want to contribute will have an
opportunity to do so to ask questions
and to make closing statements should
you what wish to interject any point in
the meeting please use the chat function
to notify myself and then wait until I
invite you just speak any such
interjections should be kept to a
minimum and it would be helpful if for
the purposes of the minutes you can
introduce yourself when you speak please
we will run all our meetings in the same
way the licensing manager will outline
the case in front of us this afternoon
my committee colleagues may have
questions or clarifications at this
stage we will then hear from the
representative of the applicant and
again we may have questions at that
point they will there
nature and committee for the objectives
and there will then be an opportunity
for all parties to make any conclusion
remark the meeting will then end and we
as a committee will go into a breakout
room deliberate on the case in front of
us the evidence within the pack of
information that we have heard today and
make our decision about the application
and then we'll come back into this room
and let you know our determination so
just before we start of just a few
comments about the remit of this
licensing committee it's not a planning
committee and for the avoidance to doubt
cannot take us evidence anything is
outside of this licensing committee and
those representers must stick to the
facts that they have put within their
representations that they've submitted
to the council sometimes matters can get
blurred and it's important for me to
outline are there any evidence we hear
must be in line with the licensing
objectives and they are the prevention
of crime and disorder Public Safety the
prevention of public nuisance and the
prevention of children from harm
does anybody have any questions at this
point from the applicant or the
representatives before we start the
meeting
nope mr. Hinchcliffe if you'd like to
outline the application this afternoon
please arrange the licensing officer
thank you chair members of the license
and subcommittee members are requested
to determine an application for a new
premises license in respect of 67 Aires
Road our regards the representations
received and the requirements promote
the for licensing objectives the
following options are open to the
licensing subcommittee you can grant the
application for on the terms and
conditions contained within the
application to include any applicable
mandatory conditions you can grant the
application as a both but modified to
such an extent
as considered appropriate to satisfy any
relevant representations and promote a
license and objectives or you can reject
the application a premises license is
required in respect of any premises
where it's intended to conduct one or
more the four license plate cities these
being the Sailor supply of alcohol
regulated entertainment as a provision
of late-night refreshment this
applications been submitted by Anthony
Gregson from hospitality training
Solutions Limited on behalf of Imperial
21 joyeux limited in respect of 67 hours
Road the applicant has applied for the
following hours the sale of alcohol both
on and off the premises Monday to Sunday
10 a.m. till 10:00 p.m. for the opening
hours Monday to Sunday 10:00 a.m. till a
half past 10:00 at night the application
has been properly made and all the
procedures were correctly followed the
applications been attached as Appendix A
and in the photographs of the blue
notice in place and a copy of the
newspaper advertisement attaches
Appendix B in terms of the background
history of the premises the premises is
not currently licensed the applicant has
described the premises as follows the
main building is shared and made of salt
up of several offices offices and
storage units there'll be two license
there is within the building you can see
that on the plan the main area is to be
used for college functions example of
that is a graduation and induction
dinner parties and then the smaller
license there will be used to store
alcohol for consumption off the premises
sold through the company website the
premises is situated on private property
with secured parking the streets
primarily made up of residential
properties the operating schedule that's
completed by the applicant it contains
the additional measures to illustrate
how they propose to promote the four
license and objectives as required by
the provision of the licensing from 3.2
onwards you can see there's the detail
in bold italics of conditions that have
been offered Bari and should the license
be granted
we forward to the consultation the
responsible authorities have all been
consulted that no representations have
been received from responsible
authorities there are however been 21
representations and they've been
submitted by other persons including a
petition these representations are
concerned with the crime disorder and
public nuisance
they're attached as Appendix II the copy
of the report and our representations
received have been sent to the applicant
and those have made representations have
been formed at the time and the day of
the license and subcommittee and have
been informed of their right to attend
virtually finally chair conditions may
only be attached to the premises license
where deemed appropriate for the
promotion license objectives they must
be proportionate and they must not
duplicate any existing provisions
contained in other legislation and
justification behind a refusal or even
the attachment of conditions must be
given to the applicant there is a right
of appeal to magistrate's court within
21 days and the date of the applicant is
no inspiring the decision for licensing
subcommittee Thank You chair that
concludes the report thank you and
cancel Johnathan you just pop your
camera on please I don't know councillor
Jarmon or council the bottom got any
questions at all at this point
yes yeah I do have one yeah
it's just a point of clarification on
the the premises I believe it says it is
used as a form of Chinese community
center or an educational establishment
as well you know is that is that not
correct
mr. Gregson will outline that in his in
his statement councilor both right okay
mrs. mr. Gregson yes I'm mr. Gregson can
you just put your camera on for us when
you're speaking just so we can we can
see I'm apologies for our for our delay
and we can give you 15 minutes now if
you'd like to outline the application in
front of us thank you yes sure so um
when applying for the premises license
we definitely wanted to ensure the
licensing objectives will be met and the
licensable activity that we've applied
for for the retail sale of alcohol for
on and off the premises wouldn't impact
the community in any negative manner
upon the application we were aware of
some concerns that residents may have
and we invite people to contact us
during the consultation period to
discuss these hopefully to demonstrate
measures that we put in place I think
mainly to show the nature of the
premises and what it will be used for
what fortunately nobody came forward at
the minute the premises being used as a
college for the Chinese community as
well as other offices within the
building and it has a aim to have a
distribution for a Chinese spirit which
is what the off the premises consumption
is for with regards to the community we
wanted to demonstrate that we're
constantly thinking of the residents and
that's why we invited them to come
forward that would do anything
practically possible to minimize the
impact particularly with regards to
crime and disorder we do believe that
the application addresses all points
raised from the representations that
have been made and also diffuses with
the conditions that are already in place
even though we did try to contact some
people - even before the hearing to try
and discuss this again with regards to
some of the conditions sort of some of
the
points that were raised one of the ones
that was quite strong to us was the
retail outlet to be used as a retail
outlet there's lots of shops already in
the area and this would have caused more
issues with crime and disorder and
understandably if people were to be
drinking on the street that that could
be the case with regards to their
conditions we put in for the retail
outlet it's the alcohol must be
purchased through the website to be
delivered and there's even a time of
which 7 o'clock where it has to stop or
deliveries of alcohol and hopefully this
would have demonstrate to people that
you can't just walk off it's not going
to be another shot we're not going to
have people come in to the premises to
buy alcohol which as it turns out in
your area people have in the past drunk
in the streets so again we can
understand the concern that was brought
forward but we think that the nature of
the premises should hopefully deal with
that any antisocial behavior the nature
of our business isn't to be a nightclub
it's not to be a premises we had some
serious consultations with Karen Packer
from the police with regards to the
conditions that they were looking to put
in place before we submitted the
application to deal with any thoughts or
worries about their anti-social behavior
that's become apparent in the area just
because of the nature of the business
we've put a condition in that to to
hopefully alleviate any issues that the
premises can't be hired out twenty third
parties so it would never be used as a
music venue we never be used as a
nightclub or a bar it's only to be used
as the application say is for college
functions and excuse me and dinners
our main focus of today is to
not just have the license granted but
hopefully anyone who's brought
representations to leave or to be able
to talk to try and show that the nature
of the business isn't what will cause
the issues with the representations
that's it thank you thank you mr.
Gregson that's helpful and counsel a
book do you have any questions at all
counselor Jarmon counselor German for
school yeah well just just really about
about the premises just a bit confused
on the plan there's a few things on I
need to clarify really I mean first of
all the title it says Manchester
Victoria College fire escape floor plan
ground floor is this this is actually
the building we're looking at can these
somebody explain that seemingly anomaly
why why isn't why isn't it you know why
isn't it described for this actual
premises tell me like to yes they're the
plans for the premises they're the
drawings that have been submitted of
that premises of as far as I'm aware
there's been no question is that the
title of the building then lunch is a
Victoria College because to my mind
that's another building in Wally range
and I mean please tell me if I'm wrong
it's it is the punch for the building is
it is the plans for the building yes
right because it's quite a large
building I'm not an obviously it's on
our own so I don't think I'm familiar
with it without like an area plan is it
a standalone building or is it part of a
large Terrace of property no it's a
standalone building it's a standalone
building okay
right so the only bit that you're
occupying is for the the area one and
well everyone an area to suit the two
outlined in red are the areas that we'd
like to be licensable areas right we've
only got a black black and white copy
but it's highlighted in heavy pen and so
what exactly goes on in this in this
area which is it just well there's no
there's no music not this licensable
we've drinks at tables yes yeah well
where are the tables has not been oh
there's no tables and chairs shown on
the tables chairs on permanent fixtures
of the property so they're not stored in
the property and they'll be stored in
the property but they're not permanently
in the property they're movable tables
and chairs they're in one of the other
rooms when they fold it down so they
throw so they folded chairs and table
get trestles portable tables small
dinners maximum 40 people right so
they'll be stored away in one of the
other rooms and who occupies the other
rooms to be honest I don't know who
occupies every other room that's in
there but most of the properties is is
occupied by Imperial toilet right so
okay so the other rooms are obviously
occupied by other people
so where's the bar area in you know in
area one is there a bar area from the
planners there is notes against specific
bar area what happens is when people
come in to do a function some of the
katrin's brought in some of the bars for
it's all movable right so it's just like
an occasional for young got a permanent
bar it's just no no there's nothing
permanent in the room right and just for
college functions
as the application states it's just
going to be used for college functions
and graduation dinner yet right so just
for the Chinese college you occupy the
building that's correct
and again to clarify that there is a
condition that we agreed with the police
to ensure that the property could never
be leased or rented out to a third party
to do another function all right how
many how many people does it hold
how many people do we want it to hold 40
is what we've put down on paper right so
what's the maximum you know what the
maximum is I don't know could you tell
me on the plan whereas Road is in
relation to the to the plan I'm looking
at it in sort of landscape form now the
right at the bottom so maybe three
Street David I know where this building
is on every building well it's a very
prominent building at the top end of EDS
Road shops in the trees the street is
the actual entrance to you on that road
follow that road which is to the left on
the picture right it doesn't actually
say which is quick so are the entrances
on the entrances on a row behind the
blue Raymond right okay well where is
the smoking area where where the
customers can go and smoke anywhere
outside of the property or just anywhere
on Ayers road or as its own private car
park right it's not altogether clear if
you don't know they don't know the
property that's all I'm saying I just
wanted to get a picture it doesn't
actually he doesn't actually designate
whether the car park is for instance but
okay just to clarify really quickly but
the car park isn't isn't part of the
licensable area which is
it's not included no mention and no I'm
saying is I don't know we're just
adjacent to the building is a small car
park around it all the way around but
again it's not on the plans because it's
not part of the licensable property
thank you Kalibak
thank you it is quite a prominent
property this on the heirs rod most of
highly residential area and I mean
what's the authorized capacity for this
building for people in there within
these two within the licensable area one
which will be used for the the whole
building the whole building you would
have to ask and someone from the
premises that question not myself I'm
only looking after the alive sensible
area okay now I believe the because of
the nature of the you know it's like a
as far as I know it's some form of news
on a cultural center yeah and they do
teach from very young age young children
as well done it the Inc Mandarin right
up to perhaps overseas Chinese students
as well that you know yeah so you've got
the range from a very young children
perhaps in in an area where you're
looking for having a license okay but by
putting measures in place to ensure that
the children will be protected from harm
if that license is granted now it said
that the the license doesn't allow
people from the community or I you see I
mean I only it's sold to patrons no so
as far as alcohol for off the premises
consumption yeah okay so the alcohol for
sale for off the premises consumption
it's not that it's not available to the
community because the college and
imperial joy are part of the community
it's that it must be purchased through
the website and that condition has been
put in place again agreed with by the
please specifically to stop anyone from
being able to walk up and buy alcohol
not that it's that kind of place anyway
with distance jokes to the community
that that can't happen anyone who
objects or being able to from the
[Music]
predominantly from the Muslim community
I'm just looking at all of the
objections have retail is all by
delivery right thank you thank you and
that's all we've got for you at this
moment mr. Gregson and mr. Salim can you
just pop your camera on the board please
yes just getting that done now hi hello
for you to speak for up to 15 minutes if
you want to ask any other questions of
mr. Gregson then please feel free to do
say within that and then we may have
some questions for you as well okay so
the last question those are my waiting
for my turn
not your Endemol really first foremost
question I'm not gonna the diagrams or
any of the images rid of me so just one
clarification Williams part of the
premises is going to be used for these
licensing activities hard for me to
describe it without you having the plans
there's inner rooms to the property just
to give a brief idea the property is
located on edge road yeah there's always
a mineral that goes across the entrance
to two large industrial entrances to the
property from Ayres Road and the back on
the left which is already used for
distribution right just to point
something out sorry
just a point something out so respected
council is that part of the property is
not linked to the carpark so there's no
access from that side of the property
external access or direct external
access to that side of the property from
the carpark the whoever would Park in
the carpark would have to then walk
either inside the property or from the
outside of the property offensive milna
streets to access the properties for
deliveries only so people won't be
walking from one place to another people
won't be parking the cars to use that
area the licensable areas from the
inside so you go into the main doors if
you have part of the functions and it's
on the left as you go into the main
doors okay so direct access for anyone
who's visiting the property to use the
carpark right okay just clarification or
something no that's fine yeah I think
you asked on this as well the orders
will be placed online and it's
believe these by Imperial 21 joy to the
consumer or with this you will be able
to come and collect these orders
deliveries deliveries only as it states
in the premises license application one
of the biggest concerns that's been
raised by the community is the access
the the industrial access or the loading
access to the Sykes is from two very
narrow residential one-way streets being
military and power stream I'm personal
I'm a resident of ministry so I've
already seen the impact of large
vehicles coming onto that street and
causing disruption because it's a
one-way access street it causes a
backlog of traffic as well
so I'm not quite sure education often a
plumbing issue not the licensing one is
around is around license and not around
planning sense that we would address at
this committee because not would not -
planning committee but I thank you thank
you regarding licensing mr. Jackson
outlined that they'll be operating hotel
to attend 10:00 p.m. so any events or
social events that take place till 10:00
p.m.
generally the participants will then
need to leave after 10 p.m. which is
considerably late in the evening or
towards the night now as he's mentioned
there's going to be four that they can
hold up to 40 participants the issue
then Rises that those 40 participants
after consuming alcohol will not be able
to leave by driving the way silently so
there's going to be a disruption of
traffic itself after licensing events
this is the disruption of traffic
disruption of taxis all the vehicles
that were gonna collect them and
primarily larger vehicles such as
coaches which we've seen that again in
the past were the events are being held
at this Center and this site there's
been a large influx of coaches that turn
observation and drop people off so
there's being so late in the evening
it's in a cause disruption to allow this
license to run so let's say this is the
cause disruption to localized
cause I get a lot of Hispanic issue or
does link into a licensing issue but
that's gonna be a considerably cuz it
considerably considerable inconvenience
to the local residents being sulphide
the evening with the licensing what the
hours on the building are at the moment
of people there on evenings at the
moment or is anything that you know
about how the building is currently
running during the day I think just an
answer to the question I think ten
o'clock
realistically being very late it's a
subjective thing to some people might
see it's very late other people I think
as far as I was concerned I think
personally it's it wouldn't be seen as
very late it's getting into the evening
forty people again realistically isn't
too many people for what you would
notice is an extra to the traffic that
would already gone down the street we're
working with taxi companies we've got
taxi buddies on not everybody leaves at
the same time so we're assuming forty
people are all going at once that
wouldn't be the case and again we
realistically I think there's enough in
place for that not to be a nuisance so
if the event does run up to half ten ten
o'clock to the license attack and if I
was not leaving at once does that mean
there's gonna be a staggered leave
distracted response it says people leave
me the properties just cause it possible
can be inconvenience and uses for a
longer period I think is to agree that a
staggered leaving process even though it
extends all even it would cause a
quieter leaving process and less
disruption from cars so I think I think
that would be the case again I don't
think forty people leaving at once or
getting their taxis or getting in the
cars I don't think would cause too much
more of an issue than what's already
there rise from that is as you mentioned
there's no permit
fix's so there's a possible chance that
once these attendees have left these
sites with standard receiving procedures
and there's a possibility of the remover
company or whichever last we provide to
those fixtures to then come and remove
those fixtures as well from sites as
well I get taken it quite considerably
later like and as you mentioned
subjective 10 o'clock is subjective but
I totally agree
Senate Locke is getting it for me myself
personally the poor being with being a
highly highly densely populated
residential area with schools and school
children's in school you know it's a
very very densely populated terraced
area so definitely cause for concern for
local residents we've got it disrupting
the evening yes so again I just think
with regards to anyone who would be
packing away or leaving or for whatever
reason they would have to stay that a
little bit later from 10 o'clock I've
done that one person to people I can
[ __ ] some tables and chairs down
staff leaving a little bit later you're
always going to get that I understand
but I don't think that's enough to to
raise an issue what with clarify there
the tables and chairs won't be taken off
they'll be packed away into a said
earlier they see there are left on the
premises so I think it's just referring
to any catering equipment that might be
taken away last concern regarding the
smoking area again will the cop did you
say the carpark will be used as a
smoking is a cop up to being used for
licensing purposes as well so I'll come
and none of the other side entrance is
wrong is again in the in the premises
license the there are conditions again
in because it's actually illegal to
consume alcohol in an open container on
that street there are conditions were
one for Public Safety
all drinks must be decanted into a glass
so there can be no bottles for people
that would try and people normally try
and put things in their pockets now I'm
making these assumptions about people
based on on on the majority of the if
there was thousands of people you might
get one or two you might be a bit sneaky
but I'm talking about a worst-case
scenario and because of that worst-case
scenario we've tried to put a stock to
that already by saying we don't sell
bottles we decanter drinks in two
glasses so there's no chance that people
can put it into their pockets even if
they wanted to there will be signs on
the door to say no I'll call past this
point because they won't be allowed to
take alcohol past the front door and the
doors will be monitored and the outside
area as well and they're all conditions
that have been added into the
application as guided by the local
police okay and any measures could be
kept a place to shore litter is not
there's no litter on the area I didn't
know you mentioned security this or
another door or where that incoming
include you know consent letters were
littering in the area there's nothing to
say that area will be maintained for a
nil it's outside of the normal business
most making sure I don't know what
literally will be taken out with them
they can't take the drinks outside
there's gonna be a smoking area for
people to put the cigarettes away so
that's going to be taken care of but no
there's nothing in place for can we also
just clarify what what measures in place
because I know decide cause I'd like to
mention I live adjacent to the property
though I have seen all the traffic
coming in since I have seen the large
amount of foreign students that do visit
the site you know considerably large
number of them I'd say in the early
teens
so what measure is in place to protect
children on-site and off-site from being
given access to alcohol having links
with someone that may have consumed well
the college is often just everyday
business these functions are few and far
between and therefore invited guests
it's not for anybody just to walk in and
walk out and just like any licensed
premises you regardless if the
protection of children from harm
there's laws that we have to uphold with
the sale of alcohol to children so in
Salem Alto to avoid it being sold to
children so challenge policies want to
be put in place ID must be asked for
staff training will be put in place and
again just from that staff training
areas will be monitored like if you went
to any function where alcohol was sold
it would be rare and illegal if alcohol
was ever sold to anyone who was under
the age of 18 and measures of the
important place again for the protection
of children from harm but their basic
legal measures that we will have to take
anyway okay just one point that you just
pick it up on something and you
mentioned there at the beginning of your
speech so to speak you mentioned that
you opened it open public to come you
guys discuss any myself I had a personal
meeting with a diner to help repair try
to enjoy a representative of the
community and after putting forward up
to 400 or 500 petitions against the
licensing application there is a
property mr. Zhu if I correct his
pronounce her name I do apologize if of
interest we had a meeting with him with
concern from the community we express
those concerns to him and he explained
some of those concerns back toes and
promised us that he would give us in
writing clarification on his application
and promises that he'd keep for the
community to assure that it wouldn't
affect them we requested those two
things from him Richard so that we could
present it back to the communities only
those that petition against the
licensing these this was a you know a
meeting that took place between was this
wasn't presented back to us so we never
received any clarification from when was
that it was soon after the initial
position initial application was
suspended on tonight approach the
clarifying
he said he sought to have a meeting with
those we discussed with him the concerns
of the community especially the
residents along the prophecy
we explained to him what the concerns
were why that those strong petition
against it and he promised us that he
would clarify those concerns and present
to us his promises that he'd keep for
the community to ensure it wouldn't
affect them those were never presented
back to us so we you know since we've
been waiting for those to be presented
back to us we have not had a much
approach from our side to him to then
communicate with him further in the show
I'm the agent acting on behalf on
outside the premises I put my personal
email next to the blue notice asking
anybody to email me personally with any
issue so we could speak and then the
applicant and they as the agent could
could give you probably a better idea at
least I didn't express that to him as
well and he was more than happy to
discuss with it personally
just coming to is when I said nobody
reached out nobody reached out to the
email address that the public notice
outside you know when I said nobody came
forward from if it was paraffin about
what you wanted to do and I know we're
just going off the sidetrack just a
little bit has anything that we've said
today clarified any of the issues that
you might have had I think some of these
things were already settled in a meeting
where they weren't presented to us in a
manner which we can present to the
community to express our concerns so I
don't think they were properly presented
not here not there in a sense where you
know it caused some sort
containment signature or the community
could accept in a way that okay this
seems like it's quite promising
unfortunately it's not coming across
very promising whose big answers are
quite big and very you know broad in
terms of course of course of course and
agreed with by the police the police
when we went through themselves just to
I think we'll end our communication one
last question car park itself what's the
current capacity the car park how many
cars can fit in it yes the reason why I
ask is those people are attending those
license its licensed event will they
need to park their car so Matt will it
caused concerns for the residents of the
area I think for most people attending
the event if alcohol is involved would
make the sensible choice not to drive to
the property and use the taxis which is
why we're working with thank you thank
you mr. Selim do cancel the books or
cancel the job and having a and how many
questions at all at this stage cancer
yes thank you sure what is the other
things touched on the bar apartment bar
area there's a ticket there's no bar
area such but where is the Alcor likely
to be stored within the complex is it or
is it gonna be just brought on at the
time of an event or yes mr. Greg sorry
I'm Council but I thought you were going
to have any questions for mr. Selim at
this stage but mr. Gregson commuter
family so this to licensable areas
alcohol can be stored in either it will
but it will be stored in the warehouse
side of it like I said the other
property the events are few and far
between it's not a regular occurrence
the reason the applications been put in
for it for daily is just in case an
event comes in for Wednesday then it can
be done on a Wednesday Friday then it
could be done on a Friday there's no
specific routine to to it I think we've
averaged before and about six or seven
so that's how many we're looking at so
the amount of alcohol for consumption on
the premises that will be there is very
little and there's ample room in the
warehouse which will hopefully be
licensed for our pottery store Council
but you have any questions mr. Selim at
all
you muted me prathana viciously do you
have any I mean have there been any
incidents you think that I've caused you
concern we mean well yes trialist
are two different things one from a
licenses perspective then there's
already off licenses on as road we've
you know we've had some nuisance cases
from there so from a license perspective
that's the fear and from a logistic
perspective then we've already
experienced a large number of people
come in and out of that property and
cause we know we will award you weight
to those to those representations that
you've made mr. Salim
obviously I know you'll appreciate that
this license isn't related to any other
license yes of course of course
we look at this completely and Oxley on
its own marriage not through the eyes of
any of any of the license studies that
is localized but we will obviously award
she would you wait to the to the
comments that you that you've made their
future anything else
councillor bot no that's fine thank you
councillor Jonah to mr. Salim well I
don't have any questions for mr. Salim
because he was mainly asking questions
of mr. Gregson but I've got a couple
more questions for mr. Gregson do you
want me to ask them now or to hang on to
them yeah mr. Saleem yeah it's just
about the web when you do have a
function obviously and there will be
obviously the receptacle for empty
bottles being collected it's just us
when that when that's likely to be put
in the bins outside would it be a would
be after the event sorry the chair
carry on sir the questions very quickly
go on my trouble reason at all okay uh
yeah you usually send me off I think
okay if you just answer the question
just about the bottles where the bottles
will be we we phone Bing connections on
site we have a P we have the regular
Bing collections all the time ichiro all
the errands
okay when do you actually empty them
into thee because obviously there's a
bin outside which is collected as you
said when would you actually empty the
empty the bottles from the the function
from the bar into the bins after the
event
no each night we that the functions are
insides of the property so after each
dinner we're going to we are like a
restaurant we clean all the tables or
the floor and also the beans into the
bigger the bottles into the beans well I
also could each night would know that we
have a function we possibly would have
so many functions all year round we have
a very limited of functions in the year
you'd be happy to accept a condition
where they would go out the next morning
yeah could you just tell me how many
functions you envisage having doing a
year approximately possibly say once a
week right okay all right thank you
I don't have anything else at this point
for any of you tall I think you've
addressed yeah did you say once a week
yeah yeah one function a week
potentially one function a week I think
he said up to one function week yeah and
what kind of numbers are you talking
about roughly to the general public
okay restate your roughly around 40
people and again mr. Salim i-ight
closing statements there's anything else
you wish to add vertical before we
determine the application in front of
all I just want to present back to the
the respective councillors the
petitioners just have been lying to the
petition again I'm sure it's presented
before you there's a large number of
concerns in the community that needs to
be taken into consideration and that's
pretty much you know as you mentioned
yourself respect to chat it's a very
multicultural community with you know a
large percentage of South Asian Muslim
Muslim residents in that community
especially the adjacent sides of the
property so as you're directly facing
the property ministry and Powell Street
a considerably large amount of you know
Muslim residents evidence and areas were
so those things are interpretations of
the situation quietly okay differently
thank you very much all right
awkward when we're all when we're on the
thing but thank you Faline well thank
you very much
mr. Gregson except you can make your
closing State
we can calibrate from there thank you
yeah thank you this what to again just
go over a couple of the matters that
were brought forward just to just to
clarify things before we go in summarize
any issues with us being used as a shop
should have been dealt with when we said
that alcohol must be bought through the
website and delivered people stole some
and the issues with with crime and
disorder been dealt with with the
conditions that we've been it by working
with the police it is a multicultural
area that shouldn't come into force with
any licensing decisions people have made
their statements clear based on the
licensing objectives which is how we
should deal with moving forward and that
the property has been there and in
operation for twenty years and that they
are as much part of the communities
anybody else and strive to work with
everybody in the community time and time
out and that's being cute so if we have
not really have nothing else at this
stage we will go into a breakout room
and then we'll make the gymnasium so if
you're all comfortable that you've said
everything that you wish to consider at
this point we obviously have all the
written statements and the petition and
we've obviously heard everything from
today so we will go and then we will
come back so Alec